we grew up in a let's see how many
bedrooms there was four bedrooms and
there was uh two four six people so it's
like my parents had a bedroom I was
lucky enough to as the oldest I had my
own I think I was me and my grandma were
the only two people that had our own
rooms in that house and then my brothers
had to share you know my they were twins
so they fraternal so they sh they split
it that's me and my brother yeah you're
about to make me cry yeah yeah so it was
like it was [__] Ellis Island style
in that house you know what I mean just
like it sharing a wall with my
grandmother just beating off quietly no
lock on the door my foot's on the
bedroom door I'm just like barely
touching my penis I don't want her to
[__] not you know
yeah
yeah no dude it's [__] crazy